look into NATO as an example we are
funding and and taking care
disproportionately of the costs of many
countries we have to do something with
NATO when it comes to nuclear you're
going to have to ask yourself at what
point and at what cost do we continue to
protect Japan and Germany and many other
countries they're not paying for this
protection in anywhere near what it's
costing
us those comments caused a firestorm
when Trump made them back in 2016 and
now another candidate is going even
further further be ramaswami telling
Politico that withdrawing from NATO is a
reasonable idea plus he wants to
re-evaluate the United States
involvement in the UN but wait there's
more ramas Swami telling axios just
hours ago that while we shouldn't send
money to Israel we should provide a
diplomatic Iron Dome joining us now V
ramaswami 2024 Republican presidential
candidate V good to see you tonight um
tell me what a diplomatic Iron Dome
would look like so look what Hamas to
Israel was wrong it was morally it was
morally outrageous and Israel absolutely
has a national right to self-defense
Laura and they have the capability to do
it a diplomatic Iron Dome means
institutions like the UN that would
otherwise criticize Israel eventually
for concerns of proportionality or
otherwise trying to draw false
equivalence between the terrorists Who
attack Israel and Israel's self-defense
the US would diplomatically say no
Israel absolutely has a right to
National self-defense and keep in that
was the premise of Israel in the first
place as a nation the Zionist project
was based on the idea of actual right to
self-defense and existence and I stand
for that that's different Laura from
then saying the US needs to then get
involved though in another no- win war
for the US in the Middle East from Iraq
to Afghanistan we have made these
mistakes before $6.5 trillion dollar of
our $33 trillion National defic national
debt is attributable to just those two
Wars thousands of American lives lost
hold on the difference though for
obviously Israel is our Ally I mean you
you I mean that that that is different
it's they're certainly different from
Ukraine and they're vital Ally in the
Middle East which is obviously critical
for our national security so I would I'm
totally with you on Iraq and Afghanistan
it ended up you know I was on the other
side early on in the Iraq conflict but
obviously that turned out to be a total
nightmare for us but in this case
they're our Ally and we don't we don't
let our allies down and it doesn't mean
we give people a blank check either I
would agree with you on that but I think
say just kind of tossing it off as well
we made these mistakes in Iraq I I think
that's a mistake well I want to be
precise Laura what I've said is actually
many in Israel don't want the US second
guessing the decisions that they make
that's different yeah this is Israel but
that comes with Aid so my view is if the
us is going to provide Aid in this
situation then it's up to the US to ask
Israel some questions about what exactly
are the objectives in Gaza what exactly
comes after Hamas in Gaza so what I've
said is no Aid to Israel at least until
we have clear answers of what exactly
are the objectives of that ground
Invasion which I have serious concerns
about but for now that's Israel's
decision to make not the us or anybody
else's to get in the way but if the us
is going to fund it or get involved then
we have to answer those questions that's
where I'm at Lauren I've been very
precise about that I I I frankly trust
Israel's uh judgment better on this
stuff than I do blinkin and Austin and
all the rest but V in the last hour
Brett Bayer had uh a interesting segment
with Democrat Senator Chris Coons and
Republican senator John th now the
subject of escalation with Iran came up
watch
this Iran funded supplied trained the
fighters of Hamas and is behind these
other proxies we need to be striking
back um and we need to be prepared for
the very real Prospect um that this will
get harder not
responding um is is not an option either
I mean you have the the the animating
force behind the evil in that region is
Iran message is going to have to be sent
we can't afford not to
act the bipartisan War consensus seems
to be back V so I do not think a broader
regional conflict or a war with Iran
right now is in the US national interest
my view Laura is you have the Arab
countries including Saudi Arabia turkey
Israel all of whom have shared interests
in the Middle East to make sure Iran
does not present a problem you I'm not
saying that that's a stable balance of
power it's an uncomfortable balance of
power but us involvement here I do not
think is the right answer in entering a
long no- win war that will not Advance
our interests and so to me Laura America
First it doesn't come with an asterisk
at the end we have to look at every
situation through the prism of what
advances American interests that's my
moral obligation if I'm the next
president my moral obligation is to the
citizens of this country yes that
includes standing for our allies
diplomatically and intelligent Shar
we're limited time but I'm sorry to
interrupt we have such limited time so
you've been spending a lot of money like
I'm just looking at what the campaigns
are laying out I think you've spent more
in the last quarter Donald Trump's cut
back on spending obviously he's way
ahead but you've ramped up your spending
I think in total the last year 20 is it
23 million something like that and he's
cut back on spending are you getting the
return on your own investment you're
you're the money guy so you're getting a
big big bang for your buck here all
these polling companies and Consultants
that all you guys hire is it uh how's it
pan off we'll find out in early part of
next year but my bet is Laura we're
doing this as a Grassroots campaign when
I started this nobody in this country
really save for a few knew who I was and
Donald Trump he made some significant
Investments to win in 2016 as well my
view is this at least I'm spending my
own money I think the super packs are a
Cancer on American politics the Dirty
Little Secret American politics is every
politician dances to the tune of their
biggest donor and in my case that
biggest donor is me and it's a small
dollar movement I think we out we
actually outpaced Dan sanis and other
campaigns for small dollar donations in
that quarter and so that's what's going
to lift us up but you know we we'll see
you early next year with the Iowa caucus
and I'm optimistic all right we're
interested in watching VI thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else